في الساعه الثانيه وسبعه وعشرين دقيقه
صباحا بتوقيت موسكو هجوم الطائره المسيره
الاولى انفجرت فوق قصر مجلس الشيوخ متسببه
باندلاع حريق على سطحه في الساعه الثانيه
وثلاثه واربعين دقيقه هجوم الطائره
المسيره الثانيه سقط حطامها على اراضي قصر
الكرملين
المسيرتان من نوعيو جي 22 صينيه الصنع
بعد الهجوم على الكريملين موسكو تمنع
طيران المسيرات في سماء العاصمه
[موسيقى]
اغتيال فلاديمير بوتين مشيرا الى انه لم
يصاب باي اذن جراء الهجوم اوكرانيا قالت
ان لا علاقه لها بالهجوم وان اتهامات
روسيا مقدمه لعمل عسكري روسي شامل
الكريملين قال انه يحتفظ بحق الرد في
المكان والزمان المناسبين مجلس الدوما
يدعو لتدمير نظام
قال ان واشنطن تنظر بالريبه لكل ما يصدر
عن الكرملين
الامم المتحده قالت انه لا يمكن تاكيد
المعلومات الروسيه عن هجوم اوكراني على
الكرملين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات